hey guys welcome to another episode of
the outdoor boys YouTube channel today
we're going a little bit of adventure me
and my boy Nathan here are going to
Spain on a fishing trip unfortunately
Tommy here has got school so he can't go
and mommy's gonna stay here with them
that makes daddy
love you I'll see you in a little bit
Nathan you can carry that back all by
yourself
show me how it's done buddy thank you we
are going fishing we're gonna go after
some trophy carp big monster wild carp
and if we're lucky we might be able to
get some wels catfish too we're gonna
fish in the Ebro River maybe doing some
camping northwest of Barcelona and it is
dirt cheap right now we were actually
planning on going ice fishing in
Michigan but we looked at it and the
cost of going to Spain for eight days
was less than going ice fishing in
Michigan for three days so we're like
yeah let's do it
so but this will be kind of an adventure
this the first time I'm taking just
Nathan along on one of these trips I
took Tommy to Japan this summer so I
figured it's his turn now plus Tommy's
in school
well guys we finally made it to the
Barcelona Airport and it was seven hours
across the Atlantic then two hours from
London so it's about the same amount of
time on a plane as it would to go back
home to Alaska so but I'm exhausted I
didn't sleep at all are you excited to
be in Spain all right guys here's the
rental car this citron a Citroen c4
don't get a mini citron in the USA this
was new Christian distinct when I met
this man yes really get about that means
nothing to me
he looked at speed limits at 120 o
kilometers five minutes out of Barcelona
a little Nathan is out like a light he
did so well on the plane I'm so proud of
him
IRA heading Southwest and Barcelona
along the coast to a city called Tana
gonna and we're going to be staying in a
hotel in the center of the city well we
made it here in one piece we're gonna
get checked into the hotel and find
something for Nathan here to eat is one
of those hotels where the lights which
is your keycard that way you never
forget your keys yeah awesome all right
nice well this'll work need that's for
cleaning your butt yeah after you poo in
the potty you squat over this thing and
Senor but now we're gonna get themselves
some food we saw a place down there that
sells rectangle pizza
it's very excited we got rectangle
pizzas yeah
well that one's that one looks like
it's just cheese should we get that one
it's just it's just you like that yeah
it's warm look it's all frothy it's got
all these bubbles in it now we gotta go
get some souvenirs this is one of our
few free evenings on this trip so we
gotta go get something for mom and Tommy
and I also want to buy a Spanish kids
book hey you want to go play on that
playground okay yeah
foreign playgrounds are always much
cooler because they're less worried
about the kids being hurt look at this
this would never fly in the US this is
awesome
look at this might be something yeah
yeah it's a Cinderella pop-up book and
big bad wolf and the three pigs we have
a tradition that every time we visit
another country we want like to buy kids
books in that country's language and
we're here in the Catalan region of
Spain where they have their own unique
dialect called Catalan and here's two
kids books in Catalan el planeta del
terror
all right so we got souvenirs for a book
for Tommy and a book for Nathan and the
books for Jacob and we got this for a
week for Tommy and Nathan one of these
two I've got to just hold out and stay
away for a few more hours if I go to
sleep now I'll be on a weird sleep
schedule oh well guys it's 8 o'clock and
we're heading out to dinner and we're
doing as the Spanish do because the
Spanish are night owls a lot of stores
and restaurants stay open way later than
they do with the US and lots of people
take a siesta in the middle of the day
so it's kind of a late to bed late to
rise or the culture I might be down with
that today
anything you having fun good all right
here we are
Medicus is a humble new store let's go
check it out yeah a little ham
sandwiches there be a little bit to the
ham and the tomato and bread that's
that's him that's from a pig's leg see
they aged it and it gets tasty it's
really really tasty look at that look at
that they got all the hams up there on
the wall it's a ham sandwich there look
at that it's just beautiful ham in there
you know glad you bite these little
sandwiches are so good it's you know
fresh bag yet they rub a tomato on on
the inside of the bread and then they
put that that ham in there it's good
there we go that's a hundred grams of
ham right there it's absolutely
delicious
amazing
it's all free-range black pigs it's fed
on acorns
it's got a really strong flavor to it
it's aged 20 months that was really good
and really indulge it
unfortunately Nathan did didn't like it
much but I loved it so I might have to
find him something else to eat so we
swung by this grocery store gonna get
him an apple see if you'll eat that want
this Apple okay we'll get you an apple
yeah I know it's a Saturday night but I
just can't get over how many families
are out this late at night you know I've
been in places where they have hoppin
nightlife but it's all 20 and
30-somethings yeah here's one year olds
and two-year-olds and babies and
strollers and it's uh it's past Nathan's
bedtime well at the end of two very long
days but we have absolutely had a ball
and just chilling here unwinding and
watching Spanish cartoons well good
morning guys we went to bed at 9:30 last
night and I didn't send an alarm after
you just wake up whatever and it's
quarter to 11:00 so we slept over 13
hours last night
geez but we gotta go find something to
eat and luckily check out as it until
noon so we got a little bit of time one
of the problems was traveling do they
have so many electronic devices they
need charged all my cameras and
batteries and my LED auxiliary lights my
eye tablets for Nathan's cell phones so
I know what I buy one of these little
search blocks it's just USB ports and
then I only need one converter and I use
this converter to plug by surge
protector into the wall then I can
charge like 10 electronic devices off
this thing and in case you're wondering
that's what a Spanish outlet looks like
well breakfast didn't end so well
poor little Nathan really is feeling
sick because
he blew chunks all over himself and the
table and luckily that's pretty ninja
fast with a bowl but yeah you not
feeling too well yeah so we're just
gonna go ahead and drive to our next
location and see if a little car ride
doesn't make him feel better maybe we'll
get a little down poor little guy I told
him not to lick the handrail at
immigration remember any problem you can
solve with wet wipes it's not a problem
don't believe me just ask a parent with
teenagers doing better buddy let's go
one thing that's a little freaky about
driving in Spain is they use a white
line to divide the two lanes so the
shoulder lane is white and the middle
lane is white as well and so it feels
like I'm driving an oncoming traffic
because you know it's all white lines
and there's cars coming at me in a
landscape here really reminds me of Utah
and Arizona oh there's the river right
there this is the D Bedoya de Ibanez the
red banks of Ebro River is where we're
gonna be staying all right I think we're
in the right place you get that alright
that's a little tight here we are in
Reba do roya and Nick and we're gonna be
staying with him and he's gonna be our
fishing guide here for the week house
number 20 say hello to everybody he's a
little under the weather here oh that's
a grand age well nathan has been having
a great time with his new friend Harry
here
Harry Harry Harry Harry
yes all right Harry Harvey I'm here
Harvey now okay Harry and Nathan ran off
and went playing somewhere so they're
having a ball
but look at this isn't this cool this is
awesome I just this charming charming
village isn't it a gorgeous river there
are monsters in there big old cat Oh a
hundred treasure awesome apparently
Harry is as much of a fan of the DL
Mighty River hunting videos as natives
and so they've been walking the streets
of Spain here Street treasure hunting so
and they have been very successful by
their standards look at that oh yeah
locusts no it's dead hey Nathan Nathan
do you remember when I told you we were
reading about John the Baptist and how
he eats locusts and honey this is
locusts is what he eats all right we'll
see you guys in the morning
hey Nathan did you have a good night's
rest you ready to catch big fish yeah
it's gonna be exciting hmm awesome well
we got the boys dressed and fed and we
go out to a tackle shop get our fishing
licenses then we're gonna start fishing
so I'm excited
oh look at this all this catfish gear
look at that
that's a buoy float yeah those are PVA
nuggets PVA mesh big jumbo mesh oh yeah
look at this
we got my fishing license and the boys
didn't destroy the shop so we've got
mission accomplished here all right guys
we've got two here stop at a grocery
store pick up some supplies and I need a
toothbrush it's been four days I lost it
I have no idea where it went
you wanna orange this is how you buy
fruit in Spain we go number 26
that's oranges lay it on there and then
look at that it prints off the sticker
and I guess we put it on the bag all
right next fishing look at this over
look guys this is the Ebro River here oh
it's gorgeous look there's a castle up
on the hill that water is so clear I
swear if I had a pair of binoculars I
could pick out every fish in there you
still have the food in your cheek for
breakfast are you gonna swallow that
ever I swear you didn't eat breakfast
you just stored it in your cheeks
all right big bag of homemade juicy
fruit boilies
oh that's a juicy fruit flavor yeah yeah
the flavorings in the boys yes in the
church especially in the wintertime you
know we got some serious gear here look
at this by the way if you guys are
interested in coming here to Spain and
doing this yourself I'm gonna put Nick's
guide information video a little
stringer there now that string right
there in case you don't know it's PVA
which is water soluble like plastic made
out of like cornstarch when it hits
fresh water it dissolves so all that
string will just liquefy into a
biodegradable corn starch see if you can
find them you having a good time you
warm the door Nathan do you like this do
you like eating dinner in front of the
fire well good morning everybody has day
four of our Spain trip and we're up a
little bit earlier to get out the door a
little bit earlier
all right so we're right here on top of
a big old dam on the Ebro River and
we're just kind of scouting you got a
great point of view here we can kind of
see if anything's rolling but I think
we're gonna go down and and try a spot
down there in the Sun well I'm liking
this spot a whole lot that we've seen a
lot of fish jumping out of the water out
there
Nathan you havin fun guys it's the end
of another great day we're having a ball
or venture if you like this video don't
forget to check out part 2 of this epic
fishing and adventure in Catalonia Spain
and don't forget to click subscribe to
the outro boys youtube channel for more
great videos and adventures don't forget
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning thanks for watching